information this episode is kind of all
over the place
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue Doctor Who review time and
before we can get to the glory of Donna
in series 4 we do first have to get that
wonderful bridging narrative between
series 3 and series 4 no not time crash
already did the one this one being the
Christmas special voyage of the Damned
before I start talking about it though
just a quick note this video is
sponsored by the podcast radio versus
the Martians Mike Gillis and Casey Doran
hosts a variety of topics and guess all
of them geeky all of them very
interesting and often very funny as well
check them out at radio verses of the
Martians calm or wherever you get your
podcasts so voyage of the Damned this
one I did not know what I was gonna
think I haven't watched this one in ages
I'm actually not sure that I've watched
it front to back since the first time I
saw it I've seen bits and pieces of it
again since then I'm not sure I've
actually done it end to end for years
now and I think in some ways I got a new
appreciation for it on some levels
there's definitely things that play here
that I did not pick up on before partly
because I couldn't um there's a specific
element in terms of foreshadowing some
of the stuff that's gonna come later for
the doctor specifically that I think you
don't really appreciate until you go
back and see it in with you know
hindsight and knowing what's coming down
the line so what I mean in terms of that
and yeah they're just gonna be spoilers
are all over this thing that's how these
particular reviews tend to work so the
whole thing that happens towards the end
with the doctor talking with mr. copper
well first of all mr. copper is uh is
such a fantastic character and also
played by Doctor Who veteran he played
such a deck back in Revelation of the
Daleks but he's so sweet here some of
the humor in terms of like with the
earth facts that he gets wrong like I
don't always laugh at those and I think
there's more of those than there need to
be but he is so sweet and endearing as a
character that I'm prepared to overlook
that but when the scumbag
you know the shareholder guy you know
the stock trader he you know thanks the
doctor and the reason he things because
of some stock is that he did that this
whole chain of events is gonna make him
rich and mr. copper says and the thing
is I'm saying copper it might actually
be kapa like I should have looked it up
but like I'm always I'm always
pronouncing these things how I think
they are and then getting five million
Corrections in the comments anyway he's
moving on I'm gonna call mr. copper so
he says did the doctor you know if you
could choose who was going to live he's
not the one you would have picked but if
you could decide who lives or dies that
would make you a monster and you
wouldn't know this watching it for the
first time when an heir but that is a
pretty heavy bit of foreshadowing for
what's gonna end up happening towards
the end of tenants run I mean most
specifically with waters of Mars and
where that goes and you can see kind of
the his frustration you know that's
gonna plant the degrees that he goes to
later on his little he has this little
mini tantrum when he realizes that he
kind of saved Astrid Peth um I think I
said it right this time
um but he couldn't save her fully and he
kind of has this little this little
hissy fit you know saying I can do
anything and that is not dissimilar to
the little fit he throws at the bed the
end of end of time part two there's this
episode I think if you haven't revisited
in a while in terms of the doctor
specifically as
character in terms of his you know where
things go with him later on there's a
lot of what at the whether it was done
deliberately at the time or Russell T
Davies just look back one who I could do
something with that when he got to later
on
it feels very deliberate and it feels
very planned I would say more so than
pretty much anything done with the
doctor as a character up until this
point that's not to say that the doctors
never had a purpose or anything like
that but I I don't feel like there has
been emotional character journey threads
planted there been narrative threads
planned it for later payoff not this
kind of character arc though and I I
really feel the need to recognize that
on this episode there's some other stuff
that's quite good
um Astrid is a fun character she's very
endearing she's had she has terrific
chemistry would the doctor so she works
well midshipman frame Alonso alone Z
Alonso I don't know what that accent was
what how are you doing man so you know
he's he again very endearing and there's
even some nice moments with with
characters like the captain and this
sort of pain he sees you know when he
when he sees Alonso and he's like they
promised me it would be old men on this
ship that he's he's gonna be sentencing
this young this young man to death and
they that is calling him some pain the
the death of the character whole thing I
mean it you know the ships called the
Titanic but narrative Lee it's taking a
lot more cues from the Poseidon
Adventure or I don't know if the remake
had happened by then but in any case and
the the sort of nature of the deaths is
interesting as well because some of them
are incredibly unfair and like so almost
arbitrary and that can feel gratuitous
sometimes like why did you do that there
was no reason to here it does feel like
it again it feeds into the doctors
frustration with everything going on the
fact that
things are planned our going along this
unfairly you've got bannakaffalatta who
is you know again a very sweet endearing
character and I do kind of love that he
insists on being called by the phone
line because you know I don't like
people shortening my name
you know I introduced myself hi my name
is Nathaniel and people say hey can I
call you name like no my name is
Nathaniel so I'm right there with him
with that old no but I have a lot that
so you know I get a little bit cheesy
but I think that that kind of worked
there's other cheesy elements that don't
work so much so the big the big one is
max Capricorn I don't think he works on
multiple levels the first is that this
story like a number of Doctor Who
stories that I have some degree of
frustration with I don't think actually
actively benefits from a villain I mean
just the fact that you wouldn't know
that there's a villain until he just
shows up the situation is dire enough
you know you you could be told like this
was an insurance scam or you know
whatever or you know you could have the
just the captain being like the captain
on the Titanic and assuming nothing was
going wrong and and then they still find
themselves in this situation so I don't
like the things that are good about it
and the and the characters and and
tenants frustration with everything none
of this requires a villain and the
villain that they have is so cartoonish
like right down to the you know glint on
the tooth which feels like straight out
of a Saturday morning cartoon and also
max Capricorn is really really stupid
cuz here's the thing alright so his
whole plan his company has tanked
already he has squirreled away funds so
there's no like insurance scam going on
here this is all purely revenge on his
part because he's been out
from the company so what he's going to
do is he is arranging for this to happen
it is going to not only cause the Board
of Directors to basically lose
everything
it's also gonna end up sending them to
jail because it's his plan that this
thing crashes on earth and basically
wipes out all the life there and he
lives in you know in his little crash
proof box or whatever but um why is he
been on that ship because no part of his
plan that he mentions involves people
thinking he's dead like zero
there's no portion of his plan that
references people need to think I'm dead
and even if that was what he wanted to
happen
nobody knew he was on the ship so no one
would have any reason to believe that he
died in the crash even if that was what
he wanted so why is he there what reason
would he have to physically be on a ship
that is designed to crash onto a planet
I don't care that he's got a box it you
surviving why is he even there it's
really dumb and there's other like weird
things that you know I try not to get
too nitpicky like that I think is more
than a nitpick that's really stupid but
in addition to that the one of the
things that bothers me about this is
this to me feel feels like the first
time that the doctor is really starting
to Bank on his own reputation yo and he
has that hole on the doctor I'm a Time
Lord I'm 905 years old I'm from the
planet Gallifrey and they constantly
Kasterborous you know this whole huh
taking charge speech now the doctor can
take charge the doctor has taken charge
well before this but like between that
speech and the whole thing that happens
after max dies and the the host just
default to the doctor as the next
highest authority figure which again
sorry but like
five minutes prior to this the entire
reason he was able to get to meet max in
the first place was because the host
didn't even recognize him as literally
anything because he wasn't a register
passion juror so how does he go from
being literally nobody like such a
nobody that they had to take him to the
person in charge to even figure out what
he was and now suddenly he's the next
highest authority why because he's the
doctor which you know is this whole mess
ionic thing which I just don't care for
and you know we we got a little bit of
that with with the resolution on lots of
Time Lords as well and this this here
like feels like is hammering that even
more though and that's not an element
that I like in general if when it comes
to modern era Doctor Who and I do say
modern era because the whole mess ionic
doctor is a that's a recent thing
classic who never really did that and
it's one of the things that I tend to
not like about modern who money get when
it goes in for that too much and this
this really feels like sort of the
solidifying of that as something that's
going to be a thing so yeah that bugs me
a little bit I know a lot of people
complain about the hosts they're I mean
they're cheesy but I don't think they're
that much easier than other cheesy stuff
that I'm okay with so I'm not really
gonna hold much against the hosts you
know as in terms of you know their look
in their function and all of that but
again even though I've spent the latter
half of this review complaining pretty
harshly because yeah the things that I
don't like about this I think are that
are quite bad but like I said there this
is actually better than I remember it
better than I give it then I've
previously given it credit for and and
i'm glad i rewatch it because i i do
think that if you haven't checked this
one out in a long time it is worth
revisiting because especially with the
knowledge of what happens later on
there's layer
you may have missed before so voyage of
the Damned you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it's tough to do
patreon it's a big one there's nothing
like sound there's there's my peel box
there's merch check it out click on the
buttons they take you places or don't
because at the end of the day folks
you're the council
I'm just running the meeting so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]